- [Narrator] Is this a sandwich?
How about this?
Or this?
The answer is, well, it depends.
- [Neal] It's actually surprisingly
complicated jurisdiction scheme.
- [Narrator] That's Neal
Fortin, he's a professor
of food law, he wrote the
book on it, literally.
Just what a sandwich is
is actually defined by the government.
Federally, it's the USDA and the FDA.
Defining something
matters because it changes
how it's inspected and regulated.
- [Neal] The hot dog is regulated by USDA,
but a hot dog on a bun
is regulated by FDA.
A sandwich doesn't have actually
a strict legal definition,
it's more of the common term.
- [Narrator] That can lead
to some heated arguments
by sandwich purists,
according to the USDA,
the hot dog is not a sandwich,
but the dictionary says it is,
and so does the state of New York.
New York is pretty inclusive
on the sandwich question.
- Hi, I'm David Greco,
this is Mike's Deli,
in the real Little Italy of the Bronx.
Our list of sandwiches is
at least 50 sandwiches,
we have The Bronx Tale, The Michelangelo,
The Sophia Loren, The Raging
Bull, The Yankee Big Boy.
Come on, I'll make you one special.
That's a New York sandwich.
- [Narrator] According to
the state's Department of
Taxation and Finance,
not only is a hot dog
a sandwich, but so is a burrito.
That's because a burrito counts as a wrap,
which in New York is a sandwich.
Okay, so what about this?
It looks and acts like a sandwich.
- [Neal] Is an ice cream
sandwich a sandwich?
I would say that ice cream sandwich
is a fanciful name
rather than an actual use
of the word sandwich
in a traditional sense.
- [Narrator] Fanciful
name, delicious sandwich.
The USDA disagrees, but what do they know?
However a sandwich is
defined, we know that they're
all kinds of delicious.
- [Neal] Food law is, it's both simpler
and much more complicated
than it looks on the surface.
- [Narrator] Thanks Neal.